from the moment she first snapped her
fingers in time to the Addams Family
theme song Christina Ricci was a star
but despite making it to adulthood free
of scandal or addiction it seems like
Christina Ricci just doesn't get the
role she deserves here's a look at why
Hollywood won't cast Christina Ricci
anymore typecast Christina Ricci was
just nine years old when she scored her
first feature film role in mermaids
where she all but stole the show from
her co-stars went on a Ryder and Cher
the following year she snagged the role
of Wednesday Addams in the first Addams
Family movie and her status as a
pint-sized preteen Hollywood icon was
complete but that role was actually a
little too iconic even now it's hard to
shake the image of her with that scowl
and those twin black braids and she
hasn't been helped by the fact that she
apparently doesn't age so even though
it's been a quarter of a century since
Addams Family came out fans and
filmmakers alike continue to think of
her as that precocious kid and that kind
of typecasting can be a death sentence
in Hollywood overcompensating
in the same way certain Disney stars hid
the scandal circuit a little too hard at
an effort to shed their family-friendly
images Christina Ricci went through a
period in her late teens and early 20s
where she really tried to push the
envelope and establish herself as a
grown-up actress the opposite of sex 200
cigarettes Buffalo 66 and a turn in John
Waters pecker all proved that she could
hang tough in dirty sexy sleazy limit
pushing roles but it also may have been
a little too much at once eclipsed by a
monster in 2003 Christina Ricci scored
what should have been the role that
catapulted her onto the a-list playing
selbee the girlfriend of serial killer
Aileen Wuornos in the terrifying biopic
monster only instead of earning mass
accolades for her nuanced heartbreaking
performance Ricci went virtually
unnoticed in the film because the
performance by an almost unrecognizable
Charlize Theron soaked up the entire
spotlight my incredible incredible
leading lady Christina Ricci who I
couldn't have done this film
oh you are truly the unsung hero of this
phone to her credit reach she was
gracious about it telling The Advocate I
like to think I also made a dramatic
physical transformation so it would hurt
me a little bit when people said that
but from the very beginning I understood
it was char Lisa's passion project
I took the part of cel beat knowing that
I was going to be a supporting part of
that experience so it never seemed weird
to me at the time she lost confidence
many actresses struggle with body image
and Ricci is sadly no different telling
premier magazine about her struggles
with anorexia I know that had I been
thinner at the time my indie movies were
hitting I could have been in a much
better position in my career and she's
also had issues with her height saying
I'm 5-1 first thing in the morning and I
tend to look really small on camera I
can probably go as far as Holly Hunter
went then I think that's going to be it
I have a feeling I am way too small well
when you're shorter than a smurf time
off after her 2012 comeback film Bellamy
flops Ricci took some time off from the
industry to start a family the move
didn't exactly help keep her in the
Hollywood spotlight but Ricci says it's
done wonders for her outlook on her
career and life having a child changed
everything it's made everything in my
life actually important and matter I now
have to take things seriously and I
never did before I want to succeed for
him my choices matter more second chance
now that she stopped fighting against
her public image Ricci has begun what
may be a major comeback by embracing it
instead with roles in lizzie borden and
the TV series z the beginning of
everything and her new Zen attitude
shows I've always sort of trusted my
instincts if you grab if you if you do
the things that you'd actually gravitate
towards and there's going to be a
through line through your career and all
your choices are going to reflect really
who you are and and your tastes at this
point in her life as a wife mother and
showbiz professional with nearly three
decades of experience under her belts
Ricci knows exactly what her taste is
and what kind of role she intends to
play from now on as she put it I really
love a crazy person thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]